je m'appelle kubo la plupart du temps je
m'occupe de ma mère il était comment mon
père il te ressembler beaucoup il était
beau et fort qu antoine on arrête je
mets de la magie dans mes histoires
si vous devez cligner des yeux faites
vite il parle logo bataille épique de
vieilles de monde mais j'étais loin
d'imaginer qu'en fait mais histoire
était vraie cour il faut que tu
retrouves la revue que ton père fait un
seul chance
cobo qui êtes vous
la famille est extrêmement puissante
tamer à utiliser la magie pour te sauver
et pour me donner vie je suis là pour te
protéger et pour ça il faut que tu
m'obéissent attention pas de singeries
avec moi
as tu déjà vu se sert mois évidemment
c'est un miracle j'ai retrouvé le fils
de mon bracket est désormais makatu on
ne sait absolument rien de toi parce que
tu sais tirer des flèches dans un mur
fois impressionnant c'est la première
fois que j'arrive à faire ça
tes pouvoirs magiques sont de plus en
plus fort tu dois apprendre à les
maîtriser
surtout ne touchez à rien chez lui
vous inquiétez pas sûr non j'ai pas sûr
en fait
tu est l'héritier légitime au congo
donne à cette histoire une fin heureuse
tu veux que je t'aime
non non non c'est